[Music]
joining me this week is a mathematician
an economist and the managing director
of teal Capital Eric Weinstein and
welcome to the Rubin report it's great
to be here thanks there economist
mathematician managing director these
are big words that I'm throwing at those
impostor if I and impostor you're not
supposed to say that at the beginning oh
no I'm actually I got over my imposter
syndrome by embracing the impostor
quality and in fact I learned this from
Jim Watson the co-discoverer of the
structure of DNA and he's he had this
brilliant insight which was if you're
going to do anything big you were by
definition unqualified to do it so that
just opened up a huge swath of new
territory oh man I may have to change my
bio and my website after hearing that
there's so much I want to talk to you
about and we're gonna do it in parts
because there's a lot between math and
economics and I want to talk public
policy with you and politics and all of
that stuff let's start with the math
thing because I was never good at math I
was not a math science guy that's why I
bring on people to discuss those things
I was always an English social studies
guy what do you have in your brain that
the non math person doesn't have this is
a really interesting question because I
also was not good at math really yeah
and I would say that in fact somewhere
buried in my tweet stream is the claim
that if you didn't major in math you
have no idea whether you're good at it
or not good and what I found was that
when things got supposedly more advanced
they actually got simpler because
mathematicians started revealing what
was powering all of the math that you'd
previously learn and so if you're really
good at thinking fundamentally as I
think you are and many people who come
on the show or particularly gifted that
particular thing they would find in my
opinion that higher level math might
actually be easier because it's more
honest and it's more complete and there
are no gaps and nobody's pulling the
wool over your eyes so when was that
moment for you that you went from I'm
not into this or I'm not good at it to
now oh now I see this other is a very
everything I went to the University of
Pennsylvania in Philadelphia and they
had a language requirement I tried
taking French and I found that I had no
ability to complete it so I figured I
wouldn't graduate from college and as a
result I just said if the language of
the universe is written in mathematics
in particular in differential geometry
it would be crazy if I'm not going to be
able to graduate from college not to at
least learn the language of reality and
so I just took all upper level math
classes the language of reality I like
that is that people say that's what math
is it's well it to me you know you could
you could hope to read classical Arabic
or Hebrew or some ancient language to
get closer to creation but for me I
believe that it were there a creator his
book is written or her book in the
language of differential geometry and
its consequences and so that's the way I
approached it and then I found quite to
my surprise that I was really good at
something that I had never previously
been good at yeah
was there a specific moment I mean do
you remember sitting there pen to paper
but you thought this is it well there
was a terrible course in abstract
algebra which is exciting algebra we
sounds elementary but it's arbitrarily
difficult and interesting I was it
sounds alimentary depending on who you
talk I wasn't what is that like I write
11th grade I did not do well so this
this is a the algebra let's say of
symmetry and I was taking a course and I
was infatuated with a young woman and I
found that I didn't show up to class as
much as I should and I did very poorly
on a midterm and my friend was taking
the class told me that the professor had
a problem that if you could solve that
problem you could get an a-plus in the
class and not have to take the final
exam and said I was bombing I tried my
look at that and it yielded and that was
a shock because I had been pretty good
student to age 10 and I had a period
between 10 and and 16 when I went off to
college where I was lost because of
various learning issues I was
not a standard student and then this was
sort of redemption and regaining this
kind of power and ease and a love of the
beauty of mathematics yeah is it tough
to sort of view the world through the
mathematical prism when we live in a
time when that seemingly is so not
rewarded when sort of having facts and
knowledge and evidence is not rewarded
and your brain operates in that space
well it's a great question I think that
the weird part about it is of course
that there is this layer underneath this
social layer so we're talking about
politics and we're talking about
entertainment and how many clicks and
all these things but if you look at the
technology that's supporting all of this
mathematics and completely rigorous
thinking is underpinning the
infrastructure and if you're willing to
dig a little bit more deeply I think
that what you find is mathematics and
rigorous thinking has never been more
important but the problem is is that
computers and Technology have sort of
provided us with what I call a half half
silvered mirror effect so if you sit
down at a computer you are no longer
usually programming on it you're just
serving up apps and information but
there is a layer underneath or behind
this and that's where people like me are
active providing the the very rigorous
technical support in order to make the
rest of this social reality possible so
do you weep for the state of math in
America right now just the public state
of it oh I have a totally different
impression I think we are unbelievable I
say here at science and engineering yeah
and that what we are actually in is a
multi-year multi decade conspiracy
effectively to deny just how good our
educational system can be just how good
some of our people are and this has to
do with the economics of staffing the
stem work for
science and engineering and so in order
to get the money get the labor we've had
to continually pretend as if Americans
are terrible at mathematics when I think
we're actually really good we have a
very heterogeneous K through 12 system
and some schools are terrible but there
are lots of terrific ones and you know
we have high schools multiple Bronx
Science Stuyvesant Far Rockaway which is
now closed which have produced multiple
Nobel Prize winners and yet we pretend
that we are somehow lagging we are
incapable and incompetent it really has
to do with the labor market issues where
scientific employers are always looking
to get lower cost labor and they prefer
usually to import talent and effectively
poverty from relatively less well-off
countries to staff our science and
engineering workforce so I actually
think we're doing terrifically well I
think math is in very good shape
I think physics is theoretical physics
has been having a much harder time of it
for the last 40 odd years so I'm pretty
pretty happy with mathematics that's
really interesting so I never heard of
it framed in a Labour sense so you're
saying basically that if a kid goes
through our school system is a real
genius great at math science etcetera
etcetera that the lid that the workforce
still would look to someone from another
country basically because they could pay
them less that well I think would
there's a big critique which is that
sometime around 1970 the engines of
authentic growth within the American
economy and the world economy sort of
mysteriously started to sputter and so
if you think about post-war post-world
War two anything that is built on a
growth expectation is going to have the
characteristic for example a law firm
where a partner is going to have several
associates under them under him or her
trying to become partners so while
you're growing that's possible but when
you hit steady-state every one of these
institutions with an embedded growth
hypothesis becomes a Ponzi scheme
and so the problem is we absorb this
throughout our country and the
universities function just like that law
firm where one professor is hoping to
train 20 future professors over a
lifetime right and we had about 8% of
the country educated post secondarily
after high school before world war ii
and then we got up to about 50% and so
that expansion fueled a golden age
because you could do all sorts of things
with promising people a future while
having them contribute their youth into
a system and then when that stopped
between 1970 1980 there was a sort of a
panic and then we had to restart as if
growth fake growth and you did that by
offshoring you did that by mergers you
did that by playing around with numbers
and so the universities got caught up in
that and that's really the problem is is
that we've learned how to play the
science and engineering shortage card
there's no such thing as a long term
labor shortage in a market economy
because the wage level like there's no
job an American won't do I will
literally clean your bathroom with my
toothbrush if the price is right is
right right so the same way I have a
Steinway storage in my apartment because
not because there's no Stein ways to be
had but because I don't feel like
shelling out for the grand piano that
I've always dreamed of and so the same
cheap first I'd wait what are we looking
at 25 grand er Simon must be at least
right yeah yeah so it's very obviously
that you all of these now we're talking
about sort of social stuff right but
it's all framed within a mathematical
was- yeah I sort of I've been accused of
running a social program in in emulation
but they were here from a fundamental
perspective that's how I think yeah is
there any part of your brain that
doesn't operate in that way oh yeah yeah
yeah um which part well I think that
well like well like love for example
well let's let's go deep I mean you're
you're married you have kids right I
mean do you did you you look at the
prospect of love and family
through some sort of an another felt
senses feel tingles and shivers right
and then you can have somebody you know
like Bob Trevor so I hope you'll have on
the program at some point actually
officiated my brother's wedding and he
did a beautiful ten minute story of the
evolutionary basis of love and he did it
very respectfully so that you could see
love emerging from the extreme needs for
child care so you can understand love
and its origins in what we would call K
selected species which have to put a
huge amount of care into the offspring
however that's not how it feels to be in
love and so arbitrage between the
analytic and the felt sense is part of
what it means to lead an examine life
and I think that it's very strange as
people expect you to choose yeah you
think people don't do that well I feel
like maybe the choice is the hard part
so people just go to one or the other so
you have a certain amount of people that
are just purely driven by the emotion
part and we see a lot of that these days
or you see a certain amount people
purely driven by the analytical part I I
think you see less of them although
obviously plenty of them exist but that
choice is one of the key things there is
in life right yeah I think it is and I
think that very often the problem is
that we don't accept the
compartmentalized mind that I don't want
the space of my mind that marvels at my
children to be the part of my mind
necessarily that thinks about my need to
out-compete the neighbors next door with
my genes over there right these are
separate things and should remain right
and so that having a partition I think
is usually really part of sanity that
when the partitions go out most Minds
find that the rooms are talking to each
other and you get a lot of sort of crazy
interference and then you have people
who are incredible at it and so our
mutual friend Sam Harris I think does as
good a job of anyone having a d--
compartmentalized mind but one which has
a sort of grace and humanity about it
this unfailing analytic consistency so
there are a small number of people who
can do that game yeah and I'm gonna do a
slightly different game right and for
those people it does make it a little
harder to act in the public space right
because there's a caliph acade of
craziness that they're going to have to
deal with I think the problem when you
have a mind that doesn't mirror the
construction of sort of the default the
neurotypical mind you always have to
have a shim because you're going to say
things that are going to be surprising
shocking and in particular one of the
things I think you and I are both
looking at is there is this mania for
telling people what they're really
thinking what's really going on behind
the the eye is in between the ears yeah
and very often I don't think people do a
great job of modeling these more subtle
constructions and so you just get yet
get nonsense you get all of these
accusations you know you should you
don't understand what love is well you
know there's this thing called the pre
trans fallacy are you actually less
informed about love because you're
talking about its evolutionary basis or
are you actually more sensitive and does
that heighten and deepen the experience
you think this need to know everything
all the time is sort of a new need it
seems like it's been ramped up in the
last couple of years where there's just
so many people and maybe this is just a
function of that we're all connected now
and constantly on our phones and all
that but just where there's so many
people who are constantly the way
religion used to constantly preach that
it had the truth I feel like now it's
either politicians or demagogues or just
online personalities just whatever that
just constantly will tell you they know
what's going on really and it's like no
you don't nobody knows well this is the
whole essence of you know do you believe
that life is about answers or about
struggles and so you know it's funny we
have two people who come from the Reuben
chick line my family strongest analytic
traditions the Reuben chicks
yeah and just to clarify that for people
I understand we doubt we did a little
did a little digging and it seems like
we may have some ancestor possibly
somewhere Eastern you're some
or something rather we haven't confirmed
it maybe Azerbaijan in Baku they don't
know there there may be something
somewhere yeah yeah coming from the sort
of Ashkenazi Stern European Jewish
background I think that struggle is
absolutely baked into the analysis and
whether it's the dialectic whether it's
Talmudic reasoning but you know walking
around an object from multiple
perspectives because even though you and
I are both looking at the same bottle
we're not actually seeing the same
object because we we have different
viewpoints on it and I think that what
you and I talk about a lot is the need
to struggle decently and gracefully in
public so that people can see the
thought process and you know some of
those thoughts might be somewhat
frightening but they may be
counterbalanced by a different thought
which actually attenuates whatever the
risk is yeah all right well I think
that's a good segue to your boss for
just a moment okay I'm not going to make
you sell them up or ever don't worry but
you work for Peter Thiel and he right
now is sort of one of the the few people
in the public space that he went all-in
with Trump he gave what I think was a
spectacular speech at the RNC and talked
about being openly gay and proud and he
got an applause break from these people
I mean you know and he's now on Trump's
transition team so obviously supporting
Trump you publicly supported Hillary I
think somewhat begrudging Lee I've heard
you talk about a little bit but you
supported Hillary that must've been an
interesting spot to be in as a public
person and an intellectual really going
against your boss is very public
decision if I can sort of unweave that
frame go go nuts yeah fix that board I
don't why I actually I didn't see Peter
is necessarily going all in on Trump I
saw him as seeing novel opportunities
seeing some really great things I think
I saw some really great things in Trump
in Bernie and Hillary and I saw very
dangerous things or things I didn't know
how to interpret in all of these
candidates and so I'm not I can't speak
for Peter but I think that Peter and I
spent almost no time between us in
anything testy or unpleasant
or awkward you know this for people who
don't really know Peter personally the
media portrayal of Peter is just
incredible he there's certain topics
that attract fake news Peter teal and
setting theory are two topics we're
going to get into both of those other
work but it it's remarkable to me that
you know this is a guy who I probably
felt that I was 90% aligned with on most
every topic and so I think that part of
the problem is is that we have this idea
you're a Hillary supporter well I
couldn't have been more upset about
Hillary as a candidate and we know what
really scared me about Trump wasn't
particularly some of the terrible
comments or the sense that he was you
know this incredibly divisive figure
because I actually didn't believe that
he was speaking literally I think that
what what I saw was is that we had built
this cognitive prison where it was very
difficult to break out of it without
somebody calling you a an idiot a
traitor right there's just this
incredible language and this head of
steam so that if you try to to think in
a way that is not compatible with the
New York Times or CNN or Fox even that
you're immediately swatted down as if
you're you know a eugenicist and the
devices and so that Gordian knot with
which we've been tying people I've been
trying to carefully untie and I've been
in a losing battle because the New York
Times can tie the knot faster than I can
untie it and so what Trump came through
is he just said well you know you tell
me how you're going to imprison me and
then you're going to lose that because
I'm going to slash it yeah and I think
that Peter intuited that oh the worst
fears a Trump were probably not going to
be realized what are the odds that a guy
who's
lived a full life in New York City you
know as secretly a Klansman just doesn't
make any sense right and so what Trump
did was he trolled the hell out of the
country and what we will find out now
how much of that was real but all signs
are that he wasn't taking it very
seriously
right which that may say something very
perverse or painful about the state of
the country but understanding it is a
key part of how you move forward right
like I still see people I think you just
laid it out pretty much exactly how I
think it is whether we want it to be or
not and I still see people railing
against the same you know doing the same
things that led us here so they get
outraged over the tweet and they're and
they're still using all the racist
language and all the homophobic language
and all this and it's like I still see
people saying well Trump's a homophobe
meanwhile there's a picture of him and
Peter shaking hands at the table during
the transition and Peter's speaking at
the RNC thing or was he secretly a white
supremacist living on the Upper East
Side of Manhattan all the Trump was
excited about the about getting
homosexuality normalized I think that
the Republicans it's a belief I mean who
in 2017 wants to be homophobic I mean
you know I have a certain amount of
homophobia from having grown up and been
hit on while I was you know the
developing young man and turns out that
really what you need is you need more
dudes kissing so that everything that's
normal we can get some dudes in here
kissing all right if it would ease the
you know not before five thank you
it's a little early for that yeah um so
what do we what do we do then because I
I agree with you that there was this
sort of there was this archetype and
Trump said well now I'm going to play
your game I'm gonna blow it up it seemed
in retrospect it seems ridiculous that a
year ago most of us thought he probably
wasn't going to at least win the
Republican nomination much less the
presidency because in retrospect it's
like it now seems so obvious doesn't it
well I think I think that we actually
did know that he was going to do pretty
well and I think what we what we have is
we have this overlay in our mind
which says if I say that I think he's
going to do well if I recognize that his
energy is extreme and everyone else is
kind of lackluster and frightened right
then I'm going to be in the ann coulter
position where she gets asked who's
going to win and she says Donald Trump
and she's a laughingstock so we do this
look ahead function where we pre compute
if I want to stay in the good graces of
my group I better not say what I'm
actually feeling mm-hmm and I think
that's what actually happened we we knew
that there was excitement and energy
behind Bernie right but there wasn't
really the New York Times Washington
Post weren't reporting on Bernie the way
they were reporting on Trump so Trump
was getting a lot of airtime because
they thought he'd hang himself if they
would just give him enough rope mm-hmm
with Bernie they thought if we starve
him for it for coverage the phenomena
will go away
and I think that you know Peter did this
amazing thing at last year's retreat
where he put up a photo from Davos with
Bono and maybe it was Bill Clinton and
somebody dressed in African dress he
says look at the globalists and notice
how dated this feels he said this isn't
what this time is about he said I could
be in Davos and I wanted to be here
instead in the US with our team because
it's gone from global to local and so
Peter was in very in touch with his
feelings and as great of a chess-playing
strategic genius as this guy is he's
also emotionally very aware and he
realized that the feel was off that all
of this sort of Clinton Global
Initiative stuff and feels stale mm-hmm
in fact if globalism is going to succeed
it's probably going to be built by
nationalists because you have to have
the support of where people live in
order to build it just the way peace
often gets brokered by butchers and not
by piece necks right you're right you
make peace with usually some pretty bad
dudes if you've got blood on your hands
that's a huge plus / and particularly in
the Middle East yeah
but we can do a little middle east of
but before we get there um so what do we
do with all of this for those of us that
have the trepidations about Trump right
uh that's still you know I still even
though I think I'm trying to be as fair
as I possibly can Tim and I think
there's incredible opportunity here
right I don't think he's a white
nationalist I don't think he cares about
the gays I don't think he's gonna care
about weed I think he actually might do
some performing in the prison system
there's some really good opportunity to
lower taxes bla baba but for those of us
that for the people that are watching
this that are going well I don't like
the troll game I don't like this game
that's being played what had it can you
get is there any comfort in there sure
um first of all uh if you have this is
as someone that voted for Hillary yes
and I'm asking you for the comfort well
so but I've been predicting so I looked
went and I looked at a 2011 essay that I
wrote on professional wrestling about
kayfabe which is the system of
deceptions and first first order second
or tertiary quaternary deceptions take
place in wrestling Trump is very aware
of professional wrestling not as cheap
entertainment
but is deep human psychology how many
layers of deception and self-deception a
lie within a lie of story persuasion etc
this is why somebody like scott adams
was able to recognize trump's genius and
michael moore was in touch with this
trump is a next-level player and the
problem is is that if you're used to
thinking that someone is speaking
literally to you which I think in
general most of us would be shocked at
how little speech is actually literal
yeah even Obama right I mean sure I mean
my son and I were driving to his school
and the Obama was talking about gun
control my son didn't recognize the boys
he said I don't know who this is but I
hate him and I said really it's a very
strong emotion what do you mean well I
don't disagree with what he's saying
this is but I can't stand how coercive
his languages he's pushing me to the
conclusions that I would have come to
naturally mm-hmm
and I find this false and I just can you
please turn it off and then my son went
into this huge impression of Obama which
was spot-on how interesting how old is
your son 11 wow that's wild you know
it's interesting because I saw a little
that very early on with Obama that he
used the word notion a lot whenever he
was describing his opponents ideas the
notion that this the notion that the
economy could work this way or the
notion and I always thought it was it
was such an interesting wordplay because
when you say that something's just a
notion it you're say basically saying
that ridiculous thing that that person
keeps saying so it's like it's not
allowing you to come to your conclusion
it's tipping you off before you've even
gotten to where you're supposed to be
and I love the study of language and
shading so you have this content layer
at the moment we're in this crazy
narrative over fake news where fake news
is supposed to be limited to things that
are just made-up and untrue but the
problem is they've opened this Pandora's
box which is how many different ways
does their news manipulate us into
thinking something that isn't true or
shading our feelings or emotions or
presenting us some sort of Fed accompli
and not giving us any ability to get out
of the deal and that's what's
fascinating to me is that it's
backfiring and now you even have the New
York Times writing about can you believe
it conservative media is calling us fake
news ah and the point is well you
correctly identified that you do fact
check but that is not sufficient you
cannot fact check your way to real news
and so I think that we're going to get a
lot of people a lot more sophisticated
about neuro-linguistic programming about
systems of deception about non-literal
speech what I'm hoping this is going to
converge on is an understanding that you
cannot expect the truth from your
government what you can expect is what I
call adult level fiction an adult level
fiction is an ability to check that
somebody who's supposedly acting on your
behalf is in fact acting on your behalf
even if they're not able to tell you the
truth so I don't want the CIA or the NSA
to be an open book here's all the stuff
that we're doing
because that's not right right but I do
need to know that my government isn't
using its ability to access my phone
calls to store them and then you know
target me if one administration doesn't
like my political viewpoint right so the
key question isn't why is our why their
government lying to us a government has
to lie to us but the government should
be lying to us in a way that a smart
person can say okay I understand that I
can't know what's going on but it's not
hostile to me it is consonant with our
values and that's what we're missing
we're being given you know Hillary was
just serving up this childlike fiction
that's thinking nobody can possibly
believe this you know you have this the
the pulse nightclub shooting and people
are talking about gun control ya know
make a disenzo
[Music]
you
[Music]